[Musique]
1935 voici la gare d'orsay à paris
à l'époque le flot des voyageurs
allaient et venaient entre paris et
orléans
aujourd'hui le bâtiment existe toujours
mais la gare est devenu un musée des
arts du xixème siècle
c'est un très bonne idée construite
entre 1898 et 1900 pour accueillir les
visiteurs de l'exposition universelle la
gare d'orsay est ultra moderne pour
l'époque
seuls les trains électriques peuvent
circuler pendant la guerre le bâtiment
est réquisitionnée en 1945 il devient un
espace de transit pour les soldats
français revenant d'allemagne à paris au
centre de rassemblement délibéré la gare
d'orsay
la prise en main l'organisation
sanitaire
chaque libéré il passe à l'arrivée une
visite médicale aquaphobie et se termine
par une radiographie à partir des années
50 la gare d'orsay perd de sa superbe
une partie du bâtiment est désaffecté
seul l'accès à quelques km maintenue
pour le trafic des trains de banlieue
une question se pose alors conserver ou
détruire ce bâtiment vieillissant
en 1971 le journaliste jacques salbert
interpellait le commissaire général du
tourisme est à peu près dix ans qu'on
entend dire que lagarde serait de les
transformer en hôtel et il ya à peu près
dix ans qu'il ya eu on a déposé je ne
sais pas combien de plans qui pour des
raisons diverses de la sncf ou de la
ville de paris etc n'ont jamais pu
aboutir
finalement la garde horse elle cherche
toujours à rien à cette époque un permis
de démolir est donné mais il ne sera
jamais exécuté élu en 1974 le président
valéry giscard d'estaing prédit un autre
destin à la gare d'orsay
il souhaite transformer l'édifice en
musée des arts du xixème siècle
les travaux débutent en 1978 sous l'oeil
de trois architectes les trois
architectes ont choisi de réinterpréter
l'architecturé existante celle que l'on
doit la loue qui a conçu la gare d'orsay
en 1900 c'est à dire qu'ils ont décidé
d'utiliser à la fois la gare et les
principaux salons de l'hôtel
or ces mais surtout de conserver la nef
centrale avec toute sa lumière naturelle
comme base de travail en décembre 1986
après huit années de travaux le musée
d'orsay est inaugurée en grande pompe
les visiteurs découvrent alors la plus
importante collection de peintures
impressionnistes au monde
qu'en pensez vous pour ce magnifique
semaine le rassemblement d'oeuvres
ordinaire
aujourd'hui le musée d'orsay suscite
toujours autant d'engouement il est l'un
des sites culturels les plus visités de
la capitale
le flot des visiteurs a remplacé celui
des voyageurs ils sont plus de 3
millions chaque année
[Musique]